you can hear the gunshots
echoing through the alleyways as heavily
armed police
pour in an operation on the ground and
on the rooftops
targeting what they say were members of
a drug trafficking gang in one of rio's
biggest favelas
as the police moved in the cameras
captured some of those suspected gang
members trying to escape
jumping from roof to roof some dropping
to the ground
by the time it was all over police said
more than two dozen were dead
among them one of their own officers
among those injured were passengers on a
passing train
who were hit by the crossfire
[Music]
what was the deadliest operation of its
kind in rio's recent history
prompted protests on the same streets
this is wrong they killed my friend this
woman says i want justice
still on the ground the pool of blood
from one of the victims
shell casing scattered around and inside
one of the apartments
a bullet hole in the wall
this woman said police came to her
apartment looking for a gang member
who'd already been shot they came in and
killed the kid in my daughter's room she
said
the police later showed off some of what
they'd seized in the operation
those who survived were arrested but
killings by police are at a record level
this year
brazil's supreme court ruled these
operations should be suspended during
the pandemic
so far this year there have been more
than 250 of them
greg milam sky news